[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs durch die arktis kaum
jemand hat sie jesu gesehen
[Musik]
es ist eine reise die uns oft alles
abverlangt durch eine raue wilde welt
kein erbarmen kennt und doch so voller
zauber steckt
[Musik]
wir wollen verstehen wie sich diese welt
ändert und was das wir uns alle bedeutet
wir treffen menschen die ihr glück kaum
fassen können die noch verschont sind
von den großen politischen konflikten
und doch die veränderungen spüren die
allem zugrunde liegt
er tausende galt die arge satz wohnen
bezwingen war
heute aber ist ein wettlauf ausgebrochen
darum wer sie in zukunft dominiert
misstrauisch wird sich gegenseitig
belauern und beobachten
[Musik]
einmal um den erdball sind wir unterwegs
im hohen norden um aufzuspüren was auf
uns alle zukommen
in einer welt in der sich unsere zukunft
und entscheidet
[Musik]
es ist eine wilde fahrt doch nichts im
vergleich zu dem was uns später noch
bevorsteht es sind unterwegs mit oliver
kahn auf dem anderen bot seine schwester
mit ihr sohn bret und orgel ihr mann
wir wollen das sommer kennt der
walfänger fahren das camp liegt gut 250
kilometer tief im inneren des fjords es
ist nur mit dem boot zu erreichen noch
nie hat es jemand geschafft jetzt ende
oktober so tief in den fjord
vorzudringen
der score isps und ist das größte fjord
system der welt an der ost
grönländischen küste
wir sind gestartet in ökonomie der
einzigen siedlung im umkreis von mehr
als 700 kilometern
wir sind mitten im fjord und dann
passiert das was einem hier draußen
besser nicht passieren sollte denken wir
uns der motor cars both macht schlapp
vorgedreht bayern hält uns fest
irgendetwas ist gebrochen aber wir
sollten uns keine sorgen machen meint
oliver
pocher
das wird repariert und dann fahren wir
weiter
das passiert immer wieder die jungs
kennen ihren motor
und dann geht es weiter immer tiefer in
den vier orten
auf halber strecke fast fünf stunden
sind wir schon unterwegs eine geschützte
bucht an einer kleinen insel in der
bucht ein gekentertes aufgerissenes bot
kalou versucht zu verstehen was passiert
ist wahrscheinlich sei es in einem sturm
gegen einen eisberg oder felsen
geschleudert worden wem das boot gehört
ein rätsel
was passiert ist wahrscheinlich da drauf
gestartet worden
wir lagern in der bucht benzin und
vorräte für alle fälle nichts könne man
vorhersagen
wenn wir im fjord nicht weiterkommen
weil alles zugefroren ist dann kommen
wir zurück und schlagen unser camp
ich war noch nie im oktober
noch nie
es sollte mehr eis geben es ist viel zu
warm
auch das wasser
auch das wetter
eine aussage die uns etwas irritiert der
mittlerweile ist das thermometer auf
unter minus zehn grad gefallen
wir kommen vorbei in einer
gletscherzunge die aus dem eispanzer
weit in den fjord hineinragt
jahrtausende altes eis dass wir bislang
nur von oben gesehen haben seine
schichten erinnern an baumringe
baumringe der erdgeschichte
[Musik]
auf einem der blau schimmernden
eisblöcke blut und adomeit eisbären
müssten in der nähe seien wir sollten
jetzt besser aufpassen und er warnt das
andere boot
und dann sehen wir sie auch schon an
einem hang wird zur bucht herunter führt
und unten im wasser sechs bären sind es
einer von ihnen hat blut an kopf und
hals wahrscheinlich haben wir sie gerade
beim fressen gestört wir fragen uns wie
das ganze hier weiter gehen würde wenn
unser motor wieder verreckt und wir an
land müssten
wenn sie kommen versuchen wir sie zu
vertreiben indem wir die luft schießen
da ist noch einer
aber erst einmal scheinen die eisbären
angst vor uns zu haben
an land ein kadaver die reste eines nav
als jäger hätten ihn geschossen aber die
bären hätten sich wohl durchgesetzt
meint ackerl dinar waljagd werde immer
schwieriger menschen und bären hätten in
den letzten beiden jahren konkurrenz
bekommen
killer wales und ein großes problem für
die jäger denn sie fressen robben nahe
wale und andere phase
und die kommen dann nicht mehr zu uns in
den fjord wenn es zu viele killerwale
dieses jahr haben die jäger zum ersten
mal an dem killerwal erlegt
und noch etwas habe sich hier im fjord
verändert zum ersten mal hätten sie
dieses jahr kabeljau und lachse gefangen
es waren nur wenige lachse sehr wenige
vielleicht noch nicht mal 10
niemand hatte jemals zuvor lachs
gefangen
wir müssen uns beeilen noch haben wir
das sommerlager nicht erreicht je länger
wir hinein fahren desto länger bräuchten
wir zurück zum not camp wenn es dunkel
wird aber wäre das sehr gefährlich bei
all den eisbergen die durch den fjord
seine seit name trifft
an den hängen immer wieder wesen wie aus
einer anderen zeit moschusochsen die mit
ihren langen dicken fellen der kälte
auch im arktischen winter trotzen
stundenlang geht es weiter durch das
wasser bei temperaturen von jetzt etwa
minus 15 grad als wir uns dem camp
nähern und dann umdrehen nicht mehr zu
denken ist fakt ackerloh nicht lange als
vor uns plötzlich eine geschlossene
eisdecke auftaucht
unser kleines boot da zum eisbrecher
[Musik]
als wir an land gehen und unser lager
aufschlagen ist klar wir haben etwas
geschafft was bislang als unmöglich galt
fast 300 kilometer in den fjord hinein
mitten im oktober
um diese zeit sollte eigentlich schon
das packeis aus dem norden hier
angekommen sein aber aus welchem grund
auch immer ist kein eis da durch das
packeis wird es insgesamt kälter und das
mehr friert schneller zu weil es kein
park als gegeben hat dieses jahr konnten
wir hier überhaupt so weit kommen es
hätte eigentlich alles längst gefroren
sein müssen
wir bauen unser zelt auf bei minus 15
grad in
den kleinen jagdhütten ist kein platz
für uns und unsere ausrüstung aber wir
sind vorbereitet mit klicken
schlafsäcken und moschusochsen feld
während wir am aufbauen sind koch
tallinner das abendessen in ihrer
kleinen sommer hält
das ist mink wahl haut mit fleisch
ich mache das in einer reissuppe das ist
ein sehr traditionelles gericht bei uns
als fleisch nehmen wir alles mögliche
moschusochse seehund barros und das ist
jetzt mink wahl
vergessen wir draußen bei bitterer kälte
mink war gulasch grob zerteilt das
fleisch mit großen fed blumen inui
delikatessen der aber unsere greenhorn
zungen und mägen völlig überfordert
hungrig wollen wir uns nach diesem
langen tag in unsere schlafsäcke rollen
aber daraus wird nichts wie
aus dem nichts ein starker wind ein
sturm
wir müssen zählt und ausrüstungen
sicherheit bringen damit nicht alles von
wind und wasser weggewaschen wird
gallen auge gehen auf die boote
versuchen sie auf die wind abgewandten
seite der bucht zu bringen
haben angst dass wind und wellen den
anker lösen und die boote gegen einen
felsen schmettern können
dann aber hätten wir alle ein großes
problem so weit weg von jeglicher hilfe
und wären wir alle mit wind und wetter
kämpfen bahnt sich am himmel ein ganz
anderes naturschauspiel an eines das uns
versöhnt mit dieser rauen wilden nacht
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen die boote sind zurück
der sturm ist vorbei wir müssen uns erst
mal wieder sortieren
in der nacht hatten wir alles nur
schnell zusammengelegt und gesicherte
und alu haben die ganze nacht auf den
boden wache gehalten und man spürt ihnen
die erschöpfung an
im camp haben wir besuch bekommen aber
wir haben genügend vorräte dabei
was uns irritiert ist die temperatur
ist das normal für diese jahreszeit nein
müsste eigentlich - zehn seiten
einen temperaturanstieg um 16 grad in
wenigen stunden im herbst das käme hier
immer wieder mal vor meinte noch aber in
den letzten jahren sei es deutlich mehr
geworden auch die sommer hätten sich
verändert sagt alina
diesen sommer hat es sehr viel geregnet
eigentlich den ganzen sommer aber wir
hatten auch ein paar sehr schöne heiße
tage aber es regnet mehr als normal
weil der sturm aber die wärme gebracht
hat für uns die gelegenheit noch weiter
in den fjord vorzustoßen
das eis durch das ackerloh gestern noch
brechen musste ist vor dem camp
vollständig verschwunden
es wird ein ganz besonderer tag für alle
ein tag den sie niemals vergessen wird
[Musik]
bei strahlendem sonnenschein und
frühlingshaften temperaturen
gleiten wir durch den spiegelglatten
fjord hindurch zwischen märchenhaft
anmutenden wesen aus oft hunderttausende
jahre altem eis
[Musik]
bevor wir los gefahren sind habe ich
meiner mutter gesagt dass ich meinen
geburtstag noch nie im fjord gefeiert
normalerweise ist im oktober ja alles
zugefroren so dass wir mit dem boot gar
nicht hierher fahren können
ich war immer neidisch auf meinen bruder
seit ich ein kind war hat er mein bruder
seine geburtstage immer im fjord
gefeiert weil er im august geburtstag
hat aber jetzt feiere ich meinen
geburtstag im oktober auch im fjord zum
allerersten mal
normalerweise wäre ich jetzt im dorf mit
meiner familie beim kaffee mit unserer
traditionellen feier
aber das hier ist anders
es ist so schön das werde ich nie
vergessen
auch wir sind überwältigt von dieser
reinen schönheit die mit all ihren
formen unsere fantasie anregt und uns
den kopf verdreht
nur das leise plätschern des
schmelzenden eises kündet von einem
unheil dass dieser zauber welt
bevorsteht
wir haben uns vergessen in dieser welt
plötzlich bildet sich dickes eis nichts
geht mehr
calhoun onliner sucht nach einem ausweg
checken die lage sie entscheiden sich
fürs umdrehen bevor auch unsere durchs
eis gebrochenen fahrrinne dick zufrieden
wer hier leben hat keine zeit lange zu
fackeln
und wir fragen uns wie sich allein an
ihrem 23
geburtstag wohl ihre zukunft vorstellt
ich werde studieren und kapitänen werden
im januar fange ich damit an in dänemark
ich möchte mehr lehrer mehr von der welt
sehen
die jobs die frauen üblicherweise machen
sowie krankenschwester sängerin
zahnärztin oder irgendwas mit kindern
das ist mir zu langweilig
ich möchte ein vorbild sein für alle
frauen und mädchen und sie dazu
ermutigen das zu machen wozu sie lust
haben und sich nicht von der
gesellschaft vorschreiben zu lassen was
sie tun sollen
mach dein eigenes ding
wir sind zu spät aufgebrochen ein
schneesturm mode und sein
sicht wird immer schlechter und es wird
dunkel
jetzt ist die sicht gleich null mit
unseren mobilen gps geräten helfen wir
ackerl und orgel bei der navigation
entlang der küste und hoffen dass wir
nicht in einen eisberg rauschen
wir schaffen es schließlich nach ithaka
toni
am nächsten morgen müssen wir aufbrechen
wir haben eine verabredung in der
barentssee auf der anderen seite des
arktischen ozeans wir müssen zu unserem
flugzeug zur landepiste nach einer
halben stunde aber fragen wie egal ob es
nicht besser wäre umzudrehen aber er
meint kein problem
für uns aber werden es stunden voller
furcht hosen da sie bei minus zehn grad
[Musik]
als wir schließlich an den strand
schaffen muss alles schnell gehen hallo
norge wollen keine zeit verlieren der
sturm wird stärker und sie müssen noch
zurück sie werden es schaffen erfahren
wir später
unser pilot dirk der uns durch die
arktis begleitet kennt solche
extremsituationen und glück hätten wir
dass der wind die landebahn genau von
norden trifft wir müssen es schaffen
rauszukommen aber da gibt es noch ein
anderes problem erzählen sie uns oben im
tower
man sieht den sandsturm wie er über den
fjord kommt
ein sandsturm in grüner
ja ein sandsturm in grönland
das kommt bei weniger schnee liegt
weniger als normal dann wirbelt der
sturm neben den sand auf und nicht im
schnee
[Musik]
wir wollen los bevor der sandsturm uns
und dem flugzeug ein strich durch die
rechnung macht dirk und der fluglotse
wollen der luftraumüberwachung unseren
flugplan schicken aber es kommt etwas
dazwischen das internet ist tot
den sonnenwende treffen die
satellitenschüssel so gegen zwei uhr
nachmittags jeden tag und dann gibt es
ein oder zwei stunden keine
internetverbindung
vor allem im herbst haben wir immer ein
problem
schnee sand und sonnensturm alles auf
einen schlag es scheint nicht unser tag
zu sein und dann steht er ja auch noch
dieser nicht ganz ungefährliche flug
über den nordatlantik an in einem
einmotorige propellerflugzeug
wenn wir hier runter müssen erst landen
wir gegen den wind und ein einmotoriges
flugzeug hat eine sehr langsame lande
geschleudert
wir würden wassern und dann im wasser
treibend die kabine ist plausibel es
kommt kein wasser rein
und dann haben wir noch unser
schlauchboot da könnten wir dann ganz
kuschelig ein bisschen fischen
dazu hat jeder von uns seinen eigenen
note sender und ein überlebensanzug
dabei was soll da schon schief
wir haben ein rondo wo mitten im
arktischen ozean nur noch 1000 kilometer
sind es bis zum 9
drei tage war die thor heyerdahl
unterwegs von tromsö hinauf durch die
tobende barentssee
wir haben uns mit ihrem eastwood auf
spitzbergen verabredet
das russische außenministerium wird den
besuch der thor heyerdahl später
kritisieren er sei teil eines heimlichen
plans norwegens und der nato die region
zu militarisieren
ja
[Musik]
freundlich militärische begrüßung an
bord durch innenleben dieses modernen
kriegsschiffs geht es hinauf zum kapitän
auf die brücke
knapp 50 prozent der besatzung sind
junge frauen
die brücke ist in ein warmes rot
getaucht das nach außen von den dunklen
scheiben absorbiert wird wenn wir
möglichst unsichtbar sein so wenig licht
wie mögliche mit ihren standard prozedur
im einsatz
das schiff ist sehr modern und
vielseitig einsetzbar wir können alle
bewegungen überwachen sowohl in der luft
als auch auf dem boden und unter wasser
die suchen hier regelmäßig nach boden
im vergangenen jahr haben wir verstärkt
russische aktivität festgestellt sie
sind hier öfter unterwegs und fahren
auch in andere regionen weiter westlich
und entlang der norwegischen küste
in den vergangenen jahren schickt
norwegen seine kriegsschiff immer
häufiger hoch in den norden in die
arktische sie es geht darum sich zu
positionieren in einer welt die bislang
kaum zugänglich war es ist erst der
anfang einer entwicklung
auch wenn wir hier eine stetig wachsende
aktivität feststellen ist es immer noch
eine art um beanspruchtes gebiet aber
das wird sich in zukunft ändern das eis
schmilzt und die sehr guten werden
schiffbar dadurch wird diese aktivität
immer stärker es ist sehr wichtig für
uns dass wir verstehen was das bedeutet
und wie wir damit umgehen
oslo norwegens hauptstadt
wir haben uns verabredet mit nils
andreas dem sohn ist dem norwegischen
geheimdienst schaffen
seit dem kalten krieg hatte sich
norwegen in der arktis zurückgehalten
man wollte den großen nachbarn im osten
nicht provozieren die lage aber habe
sich in den letzten jahren verändert
zunächst einmal gibt es auf der
russischen seite eine neue doktrin
aktive verteidigung wenn sie das ist das
militär wird aktiver eingesetzt auch in
friedenszeiten um politische
bereitschaft zu signalisieren
wenn sie mit etwas nicht einverstanden
sind bringen sie das klar zum ausdruck
und zeigen stärke auch weiter westlich
wir haben sie schon mehrmals in der
straße zwischen island und
großbritannien gesehen
außerdem modernisieren sie ihre
streitkräfte zb mit langstreckenwaffen
und zum anderen ihre kommandostruktur
auch wenn sie zahlenmäßig kleiner
geworden sind so können sie schneller
und flexibler auf neue politische
realitäten und entwicklungen reagieren
russland setzt neue schwerpunkte baut
seine präsenz in der arktis massiv aus
und lässt es alle wissen
am nordpol brechen vergangenes jahr
unbemerkt drei atom-u-boote durchs eis
potenzielle kontrahenten sollen sich
darüber im klaren sein wozu russland in
der lage ist die nachbarn in der arktis
werden unruhig
sie werden aktiver und das ist nicht
verboten aber es wirkt aggressiv und wie
gesagt sie sind agiler schneller so
haben wir weniger zeit uns darauf
einzustellen und zu reagieren wenn man
es mit vielseitigen flexiblen
waffensystemen zu tun hat dann ist es
schwerer zu verstehen was sie vorhaben
neue militärbasen werden gebaut und alte
modernisiert auf franz-josef-land einem
nachbar gp von spitzbergen ist 2017 ein
hochmoderner stützpunkt entstanden deren
11 fiction film erinnert
2009 10 kam ein fliegerhorst hinzu für
russlands atomwaffen viele gekappt
[Musik]
in moskau haben wir uns mit einem mann
verabredet der keinen zweifel daran
lässt wie wichtig die arktis für
russland ist
für russland ist der ferne osten und die
arktis strategisch bedeutend
russland ist in diesen regionen
wirtschaftlich sehr aktiv von neuen
steht mit mehr als 100000 einwohnern
sind sechs in russland
6 millionen menschen leben da ist eine
große wirtschaftskraft vor große mengen
fossiler rohstoffe kommen von dort
genauso wie strategisch wichtige
materialien wie kobalt platin mehr als
die hälfte wird nördlich des
polarkreises gefördert
der permafrost und schmelzendes eis
machen ganz plötzlich wirtschaftlich
rentabel die schätze des nordens zu
heben und der als 1 unbezwingbar
geltende arktische ozean auch darauf
bereitet sich russland vor könnte sich
schon bald in eine der wichtigsten
handelsrouten der welt verwandeln
[Musik]
biografisches der weg von shanghai nach
rotterdam 40 prozent kürzer durch die
arktis
momentan gibt es da noch schwierigkeiten
aber wir sehen dass das eis zurück geht
die
nordostpassage von china bis nach europa
6000 kilometer kürzer als die passage
durch den indischen ozean und den
suezkanal und sie verläuft den größten
teil entlang russischer gewässer genauso
sorge zeiten wurden auf dieser route
gerade mal acht millionen tonnen pro
jahr transportieren bald werden es 100
millionen sein damit wird die
nordostpassage zu einer bedeutenden
route für den güterverkehr
sind den perfekten im nördlichsten stadt
russlands gut fünfeinhalb tausend
kilometer entfernt von moskau
in seiner badewanne zerlegt ego gerade
ein rentier
draußen ist es bitterkalt
egoistisch eine volksgruppe viehzeug der
nomaden die seit mehr als 2000 jahren
durch den nordosten russlands ziehen
aber hat es in die stadt gezogen er ist
jetzt bestattungsunternehmer und
touristenführer manchmal aber vermisst
er das leben in der tundra
in der natur lebt man mit seiner familie
mit dem rentieren wenn sich die sonne
und den mond und denkt über das leben
in der stadt stresst uns der fernseher
wir sehen was in der welt passiert und
das macht uns manchmal angst
man fühlt sich innerlich unwohl
in der tundra weiß man davon nichts und
lebt in seiner eigenen kleinen welt
das einzige was sich ändert sind die
beiden und die hunde
hunde und ein paar rentiere ein bisschen
von seinem alten leben hat er sich
bewahrt seine verbindung mit einer
anderen einer alten welt
das leben in der stadt sei komfortabel
aber leider gebe es immer wieder
probleme mit der energieversorgung
und das kohlekraftwerk würde die luft
auch ganz schön verpassten mein ego
große hoffnung setzt er jetzt in das
schiff das seit jüngstem unten im hafen
liegt
mit der ankunft von patíz hoffe ich dass
die leute hier solche probleme nicht
mehr haben werden durch patíz haben wir
in diesem distrikt jetzt sogar
elektroheizung
ich würde mir wünschen dass jede stadt
in unserer provinz zu kotka und alle
einwohner von terek diesen komfort
dieser annehmlichkeiten genießen können
badisch das ist die abkürzung für die
anlage von der igor spricht es ist das
erste schwimmende atomkraftwerk der welt
die akademik lomonossow
stolz präsentiert uns die russische
regierung auf einer organisierten
pressetour einen der zentralen bausteine
ihrer akte strategie schwimmende
atomkraftwerke die entlang der
arktischen küste bergbauunternehmen
kleine hafenstädte und militärbasen
zuverlässig mit energie beliefern soll
hier sehen wir die dampfturbine aus dem
kaluga turbinen war und den generator
von c'est la vie maschine
ein schwimmendes atomkraftwerk liefert
genügend strom für eine stadt von
100.000 einwohnern
momentan liefert dieses kraftwerk wärme
für den gesamten distrikt das umfasst
etwa die hälfte der stadt pec
vier weitere schwimmen der
atomkraftwerke sind derzeit geplant oder
im bau igor hofft dass sie dabei helfen
seine heimat zu entwickeln dass mehr
schiffe und touristen kommen aber so
ganz geheuer ist ihm die sache mit dem
schwimmen den atomkraftwerk im hafen
dann doch nicht
[Musik]
ein wenig mulmig wird mir bei dem
gedanken schon
das ist das erste schwimmende
atomkraftwerk der welt und es ist genau
vor unserer haustür
wenn da irgendwas passiert wo sollen wir
denn dann hin
nach dem ende des kalten krieges war es
in der arktis vorüber gehend ruhig
geworden viele der nördlichsten
siedlungen russlands waren sich mehr
oder weniger selbst überlassen doch das
russische interesse ist mit macht zurück
russland ist dabei sich als arktische
großmacht zu etablieren und lässt keinen
zweifel daran dass es sich diesen
anspruch von niemanden streitig machen
lassen will
[Musik]
als das russische militär aber im winter
2020 unter extrembedingungen die
einnahme arktischer inseln trainiert
werden die nachbarn nervös vor allem
kanada und norwegen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück aus valbert spitzbergen
auf der norwegischen fregatte thor
heyerdahl
angesichts der veränderungen in der
arktis setzt norwegen auf eine
verstärkte präsenz der nato in der
region north alleine sei da völlig
überfordert sagt kapitän route
das ist wichtig für norwegen dass die
nato hier in der arktis präsenz zeigt
wenn wir befinden uns in einem
verteidigungs packt und wir müssen
darauf vorbereitet sein diese region
gemäß des nato vertrages zu verteidigen
also müssen wir zusammenarbeiten und
gemeinsam trainieren und üben um unser
gebiet auch verteidigen zu können wenn
es notwendig wird
am nächsten morgen machen wir uns auf zu
einem merkwürdigen ort den es so nicht
noch einmal gibt
straßen dorthin gibt es keine wir müssen
von spitzbergens hauptstadt longyearbyen
eine fähre nehmen sind die letzten tage
in diesem jahr an denen ist die sonne
gerade noch so schafft den horizont zu
berühren bevor es dann für lange zeit
nacht wird
den besuch der norwegischen fregatte im
eez j würden sie an dem ort zu dem wir
aufbrechen ganz genau registrieren meint
unser kapitän
ich glaube nicht dass die russen sehr
erfreut darüber sind dass die fregatte
hier oben patroulliert wir es ist
norwegisches hoheitsgebiet das müssen
sie respektieren
spitzbergen war eine ferne arktische
insel die niemandem gehört als große
rohstoffvorkommen entdeckt wurden kam es
zum streit
1920 im sogenannten 2 barth vertrag
einigten sich die vertragsstaaten darauf
dass spitzbergen norwegisches
hoheitsgebiet wird im gegenzug musste
norwegen allen vertragsstaaten erlauben
auf der insel wirtschaftlich tätig zu
werden und es wurde festgelegt die insel
darf nicht für kriegszwecke genutzt
werden
norwegen und heute russland sind die
einzigen vertragsstaaten die größere
siedlungen auf spitzbergen gebaut haben
das norwegische lang libyen am ende des
spots ist das verwaltungs- und
touristenzentrum des archipels
nach knapp zwei stunden fahrt mit der
fähre taucht vor uns dann waren's burg
aus
[Musik]
wir kommen an in einer welt die aus der
zeit gefallen scheint
alles riecht und fühlt sich an als sei
die sowjetunion noch am leben und nicht
vor 30 jahren unter kind haben
[Musik]
unser ziel kommunismus steht da
geschrieben
ahrensburg ist ein arktischer
außenposten russlands eine
bergbausiedlung in norwegen
am hang mit blick über die stadt ein
gebäude mit dessen bewohner wir uns
verabredet haben
august öffnet uns persönlich er ist der
russische generalkonsul hier vertritt
die interessen russlands und die der
arbeiter in ahrensburg gegen übernommen
voller stolz präsentiert er uns in der
eingangshalle seien klein und
das ist unser wintergarten
voll mit pflanzen die man in der akte
sonst vergebens wir haben hier unsere
eigenen tomaten wie könnt ihr essen aber
wir haben auch ein bisschen mitleid mit
ihnen
noch im kalten krieg in den 80ern wurde
das gebäude in sowjetischen pump gebaut
vieles erinnert noch heute an diese zeit
das ist unser größter schatz der teppich
warum man hier am ende der welt auf
einer der einsamsten inseln der erde
denn überhaupt ein konsulat betreibe
fragen wir den konsul bei russischem
gebäck
viele russische und sowjetische
bergarbeiter haben hier unter harten
bedingungen geschuftet
unsere landsleute haben hier gearbeitet
und sind hier gestorben der schweiß und
das blut nicht nur vom russen auch von
ukrainern und anderen ist hier geflossen
und hat spitzbergen zu einem teil
russischer geschichte gemacht
[Musik]
370 menschen leben heute noch in
barenburg aber auf uns wirkt die
bergarbeitersiedlung eher wie eine
geisterstadt
viele häuser verfallen überall stille
zeugen einer besseren zeit ein ort so
als hätte er seine zukunft schon länger
hinter sich
die kohlemine von der es heißt sie würde
das ganze jahr hindurch rund um die uhr
betrieben fängt wie auf knopfdruck erst
an zu humpeln als wir unsere kameras
aufstellen
dass mit der kohleförderung ihr heute
noch geld verdient werden kann können
wir uns nur schwer vorstellen
in unserem gespräch mit dem konsul
schimmert in seinen antworten durch dass
es für russland wahrscheinlich nie
ausschließlich und kohleförderung hier
auf spitzbergen ging bis heute
[Musik]
russlands präsenz hier ist wichtig
kontext einer friedlichen akt sollten
wir den archipel verlassen wer wäre denn
dann statt uns hier das weiß man nicht
das könnte ein nato land sagt
auch wenn es hier keine militärische
aktivität gibt die präsenz eines anderen
nato-staaten hier wäre sehr verstören
für uns
was denn passieren würde wenn die
norweger ihre nato-verbündeten zum
beispiel die usa einladen würden
vorbeizuschauen fragen wie
natürlich könnten sie amerikanischen
schiffen hier zugang gewähren aber wir
würden das als massiven verstoß gegen
den geist des spitzbergen vertrags
werden und wir würden protest einlegen
und natürlich behielten wir uns dann
auch das recht vor unserer eigenen
nordmeer flotte ihr auffahren zu lassen
das hört sich fast schon nach einer
drohung an dass sich russland die aus
barenburg und ganz von dem norwegischen
spitzbergen zurückziehen wird sei
ausgeschlossen
wenn wir nicht mehr hier wären wüssten
wir ja auch nicht mehr was hier vor sich
[Musik]
ich darf darauf hinweisen dass die
satellitenanlage in long hier werden
informationen an das us-militär
weiterleitet und sie kann dazu benutzt
werden um mit amerikanischem boden zu
kommunizieren
wenn wir weg wären könnten wir das nicht
mehr überwachen deswegen ist es wichtig
für uns hier zu sein
[Musik]
als wir waren's burg verlassen dämmert
es uns dass die lage hier in der akte
sehr viel komplizierter ist als es diese
raue einsame welt vermuten lässt
[Musik]
zurück in longyearbyen wir sind auf dem
weg zu dem ort den der russische konsul
verdächtigt für das us militär zu
arbeiten
über eine schmale vereiste straße geht
es hinauf auf ein plateau
oben durchpflügt ein brutaler eisiger
schneesturm eine anlage die auf uns
wirkt als sei sie die kulisse für einen
james bond film
es ist die grösste satelliten
bodenstationen der welt
wir haben uns verabredet mit der
leiterin der station matthias thieme
eggstätt wollen von mir wissen warum
diese station ausgerechnet hier an
diesem kalten unwirtlichen ort stehen
muss
diese satelliten fliegen um den globus
und kommen dabei jedes mal an den polen
vorbei südpol und nordpol
und weil sich die erde unter ihnen dreht
können wir bei jeder pol um rund um alle
daten herunterladen und mit dem
satelliten kommunizieren
und dann zeigt sie uns das
kontrollzentrum
rund um die uhr das ganze jahr über
halten sie hier den steten fluss der
daten am laufen wenn diese anlage
ausfallen würde meint meyers diener
hätte die welt ein problem
wenn diese ganze anlage ausfallen würde
dann gäbe es keine wetterdaten mehr von
ihr
das heißt es würde schwierig wenn man
roten für flugzeuge oder schiffe
berechnen will wird das eine große
herausforderung
auch für die navigationsdaten wie gps
das kommt alles von den satelliten und
natürlich kommunikation der auswahl
dieser station wäre eine herausforderung
ihr wählt er dann probleme oder die
konsequenzen würden wir in vielen
bereichen spüren
die welt ist süchtig geworden nach daten
gb s und telefon er wetterbericht nach
den nachrichten viele der daten werden
auch zur erdbeobachtung genutzt zum
beispiel zur aufklärung illegaler
ölverknappung wir sind fasziniert von
der genauigkeit der aufnahmen bilder und
daten werden an die zuständigen behörden
weitergeleitet
ein anderes beispiel ist die bekämpfung
illegaler fischerei auch hierfür werden
die satelliten daten verwendet wenn man
das sieht kann man die lokalen behörden
informieren und den kindern aktiv werden
illegale fischerei zu unterbinden
125 antennen in allen größen stehen auf
dem plateau und es werden ständig mehr
meyers diener will uns eine der
antennenanlagen von innen zeigen der
schneesturm mit immer stärker bei minus
25 grad
wir sind ganz froh dass wir wieder
irgendwo hinein gehen können das setzt
sich die große schüssel auch plötzlich
diese schüssel hat einen durchmesser von
11 metern sie folgt einem sentinel
satelliten der gerade auftaucht
15 minuten dauert ein überflug hier
14 mal am tag können wir mit dem
satelliten kontakt aufnehmen das heißt
eine erdumrundung dauert etwa eineinhalb
stunden und
was wird er gerade runter geladen
es können optische daten seien bilder
auf denen man sieht ob es bewölkt ist
oder einfach nur beeindruckend schöne
aufnahmen und es gibt radaraufnahmen auf
denen man durch die wolken hindurch
sieht darauf ist viel mehr sichtbar als
auf rein optischen bildern auch bei
dunkelheit
nichts entgeht den augen aus dem all die
amerikanischen nasa und die europäische
eser lassen hier auf spitzbergen in der
arktis ihre daten herunterladen aber
auch privatunternehmen wie iridium
betrieben wird die anlage in einem joint
venture zwischen der norwegischen
regierung und dem norwegischen
rüstungskonzern kongsberg und wir fragen
majesty na was denn an dem vorwurf des
russischen konsuls dran sei ihre anlage
würde für das us militär arbeiten
ach weißt du alle wollen immer eine
tolle geschichte und wenn etwas nach
james bond aussieht dann denkt man immer
gleich das muss ja etwas mit militär zu
tun haben aber fakt ist dass wir
aufgrund des spitzbergen vertrags hier
überhaupt keine militärische einrichtung
betreiben dürfen
und wir dürfen auch keine daten von
militär satelliten herunterladen
im tosen den schneesturm verabschieden
wir uns sind fasziniert von einem ort so
weit weg vom rest der welt und der doch
alles über sie weiß dem nichts entgeht
und ohne den unser modernes leben so
nicht mehr vorstellbar wäre
rund um die akte sind wir gereist durch
eine welt die dabei ist sich von weißen
blau zu wandeln die sich rasant
verändert und in der man sich
misstrauisch beobachtet und belauert
[Musik]
die zukunft der menschheit wird sich
hier entscheiden
es ist aber vor allem ein ort der uns
demütig gemacht hat vor den kräften und
der schönheit na toll
[Musik]
[Applaus]